hey guys dr. Berg here in this short video I'm
going to talk about what's really behind hormonal
cystic acne okay it can be very frustrating
when I was a teenager I had really bad acne
and I didn't know how to get rid of it so I
would try creams and lotions and put it on
my face and scrub the acne it never would work ok
little did I know it was hormonal okay so there's
two main reasons why this occurs and I'll give
you some solutions to number one especially if
you're female you could have polycystic ovarian
syndrome okay that's a condition where you're
making too much male hormone testosterone and
you might be getting facial hair deeper voice
weight gain definitely acne and that really
what's behind that is high levels of insulin a
lot of times to talk about pause cystic ovarian
syndrome being associated with high insulin or
insulin resistance no no no no no it's caused
by high insulin and insulin resistance okay so I
put a link down below on that video if you want to
learn a little bit more about insulin resistance
and how to lower that and there's a lot of things
you can do and it's you can get some seriously
good results with that okay so that's one thing
but there's an enzyme that converts testosterone
into what's called DHT the very powerful form
of testosterone which is causing the acne and
it's called 5-alpha reductase okay so it's a
fancy word for just an enzyme that converts
these two and in certain people you just have too
much of that enzyme so what you want to do is you
want to take a 5 alpha reductase inhibitor
alright you want to take a natural one and
that happens to be in all the cruciferous foods
okay they can the broccoli the brussel sprouts
the cabbage that really really helps but there's
a very concentrated form of cruciferous called
dim I'm not going to give you the long name for
it but two tablets of dim is equivalent to two
pounds of cruciferous vegetables so I'll show
you I use this for my clients called estrogen
balance with dim okay it has 200 milligrams ofDIM and you don't want to take more than that
because if you take too much it can create more
acne so you just want just enough and I put a lot
of other things to help balance estrogen and
associated things like cruciferous vegetables
okay so you may want to if you're interested in
checking it out I put a link down below you can
get more information but that's what you need
to help stop this conversion to really get rid
of the acne all right I hope that helped now
see in the next video hey guys thank you so
much for watching please click the subscribe
button and I will see you in the next video